[Music]
all science careers involve creativity
think about it we're asking and
answering questions and we're solving
the world's problems so the more
creatively we can solve the world's
problems the more new ideas and concepts
and approaches we can use to address the
world's problems the better off we'll be
creativity is the guiding force on the
path to good science so there isn't a
science job out there that doesn't
benefit from creativity like you could
be an engineer building more efficient
transistors for tinier and tinier phones
you could be a climate scientist
figuring out how we can reduce our
carbon footprint and save the world from
climate catastrophe or an agricultural
researcher deducing efficient ways to
feed the planet or maybe an entomologist
like me
understanding how
relationships between organisms keep us
all healthy creativity is important in
all of these careers one really cool job
is
is working for a science museum and so
the people who are like the the chief
directors or bioscientists or what have
you for science museums usually have a
biology or a science background of some
kind maybe have gone through even being
a phd or a postdoctoral fellow
and
their job is to design exhibits for
for visitors to to museums and
um come up with engaging ways to share
ideas in science and so
i just think that's a really cool job
that you might not immediately think of
[Music]